we are the creators and inventors of 3d
printing with the first serial ography
system that chuck hall invented in 1986
finally after a 25-year journey to
democratize we can actually put it in
the hands of kids and to me that's
really exciting these are a couple of
aspiring 3d printing engineers what do
you guys been working on pretty much
anything we can do we do everything from
mechanical tests to see if the printers
up to printing something like a zip tie
to actually useful stuff like reprinting
a hard drive caddy for a laptop the kids
are going to make the world of the
future and it's going to be about
localizing manufacturing in your garage
or desktop and it's going to be about
giving kids to moral skills today so
that we could really have a sustainable
economy I mean to me this is what it's
all about we want to be competitive and
we want to be sustainable and these guys
are the face of the future and what
they're going to come up with we can't
even imagine but that's the beauty the
cube is gonna have a big splash in 3d
printing as an industry I personally
think it's going to be as big as the mac
mini was to competing or just the first
actual Macintosh you think everybody's
going to have one of these at some point
in the future on their desk a 3d printer
yeah I think it's going to become as
ubiquitous as a microwave it's just
going to be something a family has to
have the whole point is if you can think
it if you can dream it you can make it
and you can print anything from your
mechanical designs to fun little guys
like this one and anything that you
can't do on this machine then you go up
to Cuba 5.com and you can upload you
design and then we can make it for you
for up to 100 materials including metals
nylons plastics rubber like materials
ceramic like materials so we're actually
through cubify democratizing access and
giving any garage enterpreneur
access to the same manufacturing
resources that were traditionally saved
for only deep-pocketed companies so it's
really leveling the playing field